well the tourists have been here in
droves at the Acropolis in Athens you
can still see them streaming down the
exit ramp many arriving much earlier
than they ordinarily would have done in
order to beat the heat which is now
starting to creep up into the high 30s
make it to 39 or even 40 today even
higher tomorrow and there's many more
tourists Brave tourists now because it's
so hot waiting to get in you can see
that big shade tent there has been put
up to keep people out of Harm's Way lots
of people they're Fanning themselves
using parasols anything to stay cool the
Red Cross has set up a tent nearby in
order to hand out water those are the
water bottles that most people are
holding just to keep people dehydrated
and the Red Cross have told me here that
they've had dozens of people come to
their tents for help because they've
been exposed to the Heat and they've got
themselves dehydrated it is a similar
picture across Europe Spain Italy
Portugal France all suffering in really
brutal temperatures and for large parts
of southern Europe now in a grip of a
heat wave we're looking at this extreme
temperature lasting for some days yet a
region of high pressure just trapped
over southern Europe and Northern Africa
climate change scientists that as the
world heats up events like this are more
likely they're going to be more frequent
more intense and longer in duration and
it's that duration that can make heat
really dangerous that lack of relief at
night time as well and we have spoken to
some tourists here today who've said
actually they rather wish they hadn't
come out it's that unpleasant in Athens
at the moment and that of course in the
end will have an impact on the tourism
industry